Here I've continued my wishful thinking,
and I've written out the complete grammar. I think I've got it right.
Now all I'm missing is something that understands this format.
Let's continue the wishful thinking and wish that we had
a function that could take this format and turn it into something
that we can then use in a parser.
Here I have applied the wishful thinking and said I wish I had this function grammar
that would give me this grammar G, and then I could use it to parse expressions.
Now it's up to me to deliver on that promise or that wishful thinking.
The first thing I should ask myself is what do I want this object G to look like?
One good idea is that G could be a dictionary.
The keys of the dictionary would be these things on the left-hand side,
and then the values of each key would be some object corresponding
to this representation on the right-hand side.
I would have expression--something like this.
Now all I've got to do is figure out what goes on the right-hand side.
Here I've made a choice, and what I've said is,
well, the right-hand side looks like it's always going to be a set of alternatives.
The order matters, so I'm not going to make it into a set.
I'm going to make it into a sequence of some kind, and let's make that a tuple.
The right-hand side is always going to be a tuple of alternatives.
It might be a tuple of length 1, but it's always going to be a tuple.
Each element of that tuple is going to be a sequence--
here a sequence of three items, here a sequence of one items.
We'll represent sequences as lists.
Here are the three items, and here is the one item.
Every right-hand side is a tuple of lists where the lists are a sequence
and each element of the list is a atom.
The atoms can either be the name of a category that's defined on the left-hand side,
or they can be a regular expression that's going to match actual characters
in the input when we go to parse.
Now, of course I could have typed in the whole grammar like this to begin with,
but that would have been messy and error-prone and harder to read.
I did myself a favor imagining the language I wanted and writing in that language,
then figuring out how to get it into something the computer can understand.
Now all I have to do is write this function grammar that translates from this format into this format.
Fortunately, it's really easy to write this function. Here the whole thing is. Here's what I've done.
I've initialized the grammar that I'm going to produce to be the empty dictionary.
Then I've gone through the whole description--the description is the input--
and split it up by lines.
For each line I've split up each line by the arrow into left-hand side an a right-hand side.
Then for each right-hand side I've split that up, using the or sign,
into a list of alternatives of one or more.
Then I've just said let's assign to the left-hand side--expression or term--a tuple,
because that's what we're using for alternatives of the map of splitting up each alternative.
The alternative here would be a string.
It would be the string of everything starting from term and ending with expression.
Then I just mapped the split function to it to split it up into individual atoms.
That would split it up into a three-element list--term, plus or minus, and expression.
That's all I need.
This is a description of the grammar format, immediately implements it, and builds up a dictionary for us.
I should say I've used here this utility function "split."
It's just like string.split, except when it splits things up it strips the white space
from each of the pieces.